back to kiss for a minute so the book
you alluded to also that you wrote in
the book part of the book you talked
about um some of your bandmates kind of
uh maybe being anti-semitic
how was that taken has it been resolved
is that uh
it that that's a touchy subject um
you wrote it yes i did
i did for all of us well i i felt you
know
my book
was not about throwing anybody under the
bus they walked under it you know i
didn't push him all right but um yeah
there certainly was
anti-semitism
and i think it's
i don't want to say rampant but
you know they're
andy's in the world i will tell you as a
fellow jew yes it is rampant but i'm
also
not um
at least
i don't think i'm working with anybody
where it is
uh affecting me so
to be in a group i've never been in a
group i'm a comic i work by myself and i
work with my family but to be in a group
where you feel that
and you kind of announced that
well i let's kind of clarify i
i kind of announced that
decades after
um when it was happening it
okay it's it's a it can be an awkward
situation
but being jewish isn't always easy
anyway
you know um i remember
when i first made enough money to to get
an apartment in new york city and i
wanted to live on fifth avenue because i
wanted to overlook the park
and i had a real estate agent take me
and after looking at an apartment or two
she said look i can take you where you
want to live or when or where they'll
let you live i was like
in new york yes
yeah
wow yeah so i was like what are you
talking about well your new money
and you're jewish
so
that was a a reality check and and um so
yeah i think weird in our generation
that we still experience that i i think
everybody boy
people like a scapegoat
and
i think that um
jews have
historically
found a way to land on their feet in the
worst adversity i agree with you and i
think that
some people have a hard
hard time with that
how did your how did the people that you
talked about a decade after it happened
did they reach out to you after they
wrote after the book came out no um
no
no no um
some some deny it and
that's fine you know um we all have our
own
you know uh memories and we'll interpret
events in our lives the way we choose to
[Music]